hi welcome to Sky News live for a
special program from my box room working
from home it's quite interesting I'm
sure everyone at home that's working
from home is going through this I was in
my living room
earlier this week I've now had to move
to the box room because apparently spent
a sound and a bit of Wi-Fi signal and
today I'm going to speak into four
residents from one Street it leads to
find out how they're dealing from life
in lockdown they're in an assortment of
bedrooms and living rooms on their
street they've actually been keeping a
video diary for us here at Sky News and
they'll be sharing their experiences in
the days and weeks ahead we can take a
look at one of the Diaries now who made
all this breakfast it's time for
jiggling which is a class that I do
online on zoom' today I sent a message
to the neighborhood group and asked them
if they wanted me to do anything for
them and now I've got a small request
I've got a shopping list here here's the
cute people so I do the cover and well I
also well stretched after chicken I know
that I'm happy to be in lockdown because
I've got a beautiful garden well I think
it's beautiful and lovely dog cut the
coffee gorgeous tenderloins
well we've adopted this street here on
Sky News give little insight into how
people are coping with life on lockdown
I'm pleased to say joining me now alive
from Leeds we have property agent [ __ ]
retired yoga trainer Liz and her husband
Phil stay-at-home mom of six a deef and
also retired teacher Claire good
afternoon to you all he can give us away
because he's been through a few zoom
house rules before we home live on to
Sky News everybody has their microphones
on meets until they want to answer a
question or say something and guys it's
really good to see you this afternoon
and we're following your lives on Sky
News is up online and this is the first
time I've spoken to you live on the
telly and city is worth reminding people
how you all got together because like
streets up and down the country you're
probably getting to know your neighbours
for the first time
all began with you and a letter you put
through people's doors yep so basically
once lockdown was announced what I did
was my first thought was how is
everybody gonna cope and I'm sort of had
to look around me and I thought yep
there's me and my six children and my
husband but then I looked outside and I
thought I've got streets full of people
here and I was just thinking what if
they haven't got family what if they're
in self isolation you know maybe I can
do something to help them and so yeah I
came up with the idea to send a letter
out to everybody so everyone industry
got a letter from me and it just said if
anybody need for any kind of help or
assistance so just get in touch and I
left my number and literally that saying
money so many people got back in touch
and it was really overwhelming it was so
amazing I wanna bring in lives and fill
at this point because listen Phil you've
lived on your road for 40 years now
and I just wonder what he thought when
that letter came through your post box
and what you thought about you know the
street on which you live and how it's
changed over the years to the community
you've built over the last few weeks
oh when we got the letter we thought it
was fabulous and I jumped on - what's
that straight away and joined and
offered to help because we're so fit
healthy and we can carry shopping new
things like that there's always been a
good community spirited in the street
but to be fair until City to mess around
we probably only knew the people three
or four houses either side a few others
to wave to well since they came out
we've been going out 30 nights together
talking what's up we've got so a lot
more people than can I say hi in the
street so I saw it it's a really nice
feeling that everybody on the street is
so friendly yes we interesting sure
what's that group is now 30 households
strong there's so many of you getting
involved and Claire what kind of things
are you doing for each other during
lockdown well people are offering to do
shopping for each other
asking for anything you know if you need
any help and to be honest it's just the
fact that you know there's people there
you know their names now you can say
hello to them on the street whereas
before I I knew my neighbours but I
didn't know the names of anybody else on
the street at all and is if you're
living on your own it's actually really
nice to know names of people along your
street and to know there's people there
if you need them to know that I can help
people if they need help and it's just
really nice to start developing a sense
of community along this road it's you
know made it feel very different living
here actually yeah it's really grown
over the last few weeks as you go
through this together but you've all got
different circumstances behind those
closed doors and I know before we went
live on to the news channel you were
chatting amongst yourselves still trying
to figure out whose house is who and
finding out little bits about and the
fatty I want to talk to you because I'm
in your household you live with your mum
and sister and up until lockdown
happened you were working in the
property industry and I understand it's
been a difficult time for you because of
course that sector has shrunk massively
you know jobs have gone you've gone from
leaving the house and working long hours
every day to being a lock down with
everybody else with your mom and your
sister and I just wondered you know how
you're coping at the moment well as
affected the business a lot I have
noticed that most of my residential
tenants basically desert wood to pay
rent and as good-faith I did say to I'm
gonna just mark off the one month period
and hopefully after the next month we'll
get I'll give you a 20% discount but
it's so unfortunate about this again
that look you know because the
government hasn't thanked posted Wendy's
lockdowns gonna get obviously so due to
the tenants that lost their jobs the
same that they'll have to try to claim
for benefits and it's just like
basically I'm on the edge you see we
just don't know when they're gonna get
that and also the property that were
already making I have authorized him
and it's been such a long time that no
one's interested in too many parties you
see so as it was it hasn't affected me
and also you know what it just you know
where everything that part does happen
I'll disavow that what comes out so I'm
spending more time with family gardening
cooking
I'm just a man with simple pleasures you
see so okay fatty it sounds like you're
looking at and the positive side of
things for this business worries going
on behind your front door so deep I
wanna talk to you because you're a
mother of six and this will resonate
with households up and down the country
having a large number of kids you know
in a house 24/7 I mean I think you're
lucky I think you have a garden how are
you coping with that I'll be honest with
you I'm actually really enjoying my time
with you for the first time in like a
decade my husband actually being at home
he's up to close his business though
he's been at home for the past three
three to four weeks and I'm just
enjoying seeing everybody under one roof
I mean don't get me wrong there are
challenges of course the fighting the
bickering you know that's never-ending
but then the moments where they do sit
and play together they'll play board
games I'll just see them playing amongst
themselves and you know it's just really
nice to have fresh air from school runs
and a bit of a breather I think it's
just let everything just slow down a bit
as well from day to day life now I know
you're all filming video diaries for Sky
News keeping us up to date with what
you're doing in life are locked down and
listen fellow you filming the good and
the bad because let's face it we all
have worries and wobbles we can't be
positive all the time so how have you
found keeping a video diary I had
someone comment earlier that it's a bit
like we're living through history at the
moment so what you're documenting in
years to come
people will be watching to learn about
what life was like on lockdown in 2020
well we we do have moments but at the
moment my moments tend to be at midnight
and I don't really feel like
during those we do we do worry about
Phil's mom but my mom is she's 97 she
lives down in Somerset and partly
because of her age and I think part
because of a lack of stimulus it's
lockdown she's getting more and more
forgetful and confused and whenever I
speak to her on a daily basis I can tell
if she's struggling and there's
virtually nothing I can do about it
that's not fine powerfullest yeah yes
the separation from loved ones isn't it
particularly the elderly you have to be
isolated for their own protection and
you can't go see the money said Somerset
is a long way from Leeds how are you
coping with that because obviously I
would imagine you're in as much contact
as you can be with her and she got
people around her because obviously that
will play on your mind because you don't
have the same kind of access that you
used to have - yeah yeah very much she
does have a lot of support locally I was
lucky enough to go down just before the
lockdown yeah and we arranged with the
local restaurants to bring her meals
twice a week for lunch and almost every
day somebody contacts her and I so she
wants anything
the trouble is she forgets what she
wants so by mid-afternoon
should we stop there thinking I haven't
got anything to eat despite the fact the
freezers full of food but I bring her
every day my brother rings her everyday
some of the grandchildren the
great-grandchildren try and ring her
yeah but we just worry about it I'm sure
she will be ok I'm sure feyza okay but
there's nothing like being able to go
down and just give her a hug to make
sure he's okay
Oh Phil I know it's gonna resonate with
so many people going through a similar
situation right now fingers crossed that
this is all going to be over soon and
you do get to go and see your mum and
Claire it's interesting social media we
were talking about it in such bad terms
perhaps before this crisis took over but
actually you know social media online
technology is being seen in such a good
way now it's bringing communities
together it's brought
of you together in a way that you know
you probably wouldn't have done in real
life before this and I know that's how
you're keeping in touch with your
grandchildren in fact you're baking with
Wollaston virtually today I was yes I
was I was making apple crumble with her
she was making apple pear crumble and I
was making apple crumble I don't know it
would be horrible without this
technology really I use it every day to
keep in contact with my grandchildren
I've got very creative about what to do
when I go online with them making up
games and stuff like that and yeah
without what's up it would have been a
completely different story along this
this road really and I think it's
brilliant the technology in fact I did
think about having a day without it
completely just to see what it felt like
quite quite interesting that's not a bad
thing Claire that's not a bad thing at
all and and I'm interested in to how you
are going to carry the sense of
community over when lockdown finishes
because it will end at some point and
fudgie what are the plans be able to
meet up in real life when all this is
done I would imagine there's gonna be a
big street party
well I normally do a black-tie in my
area so in my neighborhood and nearly
all the things come around and this is
the holy monk in a few days and that's
that multis all full of compassion mercy
and do with your neighbour Mavis and I
hope once this lockdown you know once
they lock down doors
hopefully it'll be good time for the Eid
festival so with a bye everyone around
and just have a really good big barbecue
that's all great and I'm sure there'll
be a few acceptances of invites online
now I'm sure you were really looking
forward to actually meeting each other
in real life yeah well everybody know
that every time I put invitation the
cost of food and having like a good time
everyone's welcome that is the principle
I be involved with so it will be great I
know every single person on the street
has helped out you know feel free to
come down well it's been really good to
talk to you
we're all in this together everybody
going through different battles behind
closed doors but the one thing that's
keeping you positive and going is your
sense of community spirit it's been
brilliant to talk to you this afternoon
we're keeping in touch with you
regularly here on Sky News you can see
you lock down diaries online and I know
we're going to speak on the telly soon
thank you so much for joining us Fadi
lism feltzer dthe and Claire we'll speak
to you soon stay safe thank you